Welcome to the show, we
have a terrific program.
And do I seem excited?
Yes, and for a good reason, I am excited.
I've been waiting for this day.
We have not had an audience
because of the quarantine,
COVID, not had real people
here, we're getting close.
A couple of days ago, I asked
my fans watching the show
if they wanted to be part
of our real audience,
take a picture of
themselves, post it online,
and we would turn them into cutouts
here at the Largo Theater.
Yes, professional sports is
doing it, now we're doing it.
And wallah, look at this,
we're starting to fill the audience.
Over 15,000 people have contacted us,
sent us their photographs,
and we are as fast as we can
turning them into cardboard cutouts.
Now, it's a process, it's
taking some time, but look,
we've got a pretty good group
here, this is pretty good.
Yeah, we have our own little village.
Yeah, we have an incredible
village of people
and it's growing.
This is gonna be a packed
house by the next day or so,
this is amazing what's happening.
This is what America can do,
this is what we should be doing,
not searching for a cure or a vaccine,
making cardboard cutouts of ourselves
that we can put in audiences.
That's the answer.
(chuckles)
Hey, look here.
I'm gonna do that on Thanksgiving.
Yes.
No family, just cutouts.
Sure, why should this
year be any different?
Sorry, Andy, pretty good slam though,
pretty good slam.
[Andy] It was pretty good.
All right, let's say hello to
some people in our audience,
and that's Carolina
Avia, got an aisle seat.
She came here early and
she's so happy to see me,
or she hates the sound of my
voice and is covering her ears.
Next to her, well, I think
it's quite clear that,
that woman is in love with me.
Her name's Taylor Rue Davey,
and she's just smitten,
and of course upping
the ante, next to her,
Tomasky Manes, clearly having an orgasm,
which is something,
it's a common reaction
to seeing this program.
There's a Benjamin Tar,
very patriotic Benjamin Tar.
Good-looking American right
there, enjoying the show.
And next to Benjamin Tar
is a cat named Pablo,
doesn't seem to be that
thrilled with the show,
Pablo is waiting for something
funny to happen so far--
[Andy] More mouse content.
More mouse (laughs), more mouse content,
that's what Pablo wants,
Andy, I think you're right.
Andy, speaking of which,
who is that next to you?
They seem like a little
afraid of the show.
This is my buddy, Jayden Barns.
Why are you so nervous, Jayden?
Come on.
Yeah, well, you're getting
a little handsy with him.
Yeah, well, I mean, I liked this,
it's called fan outreach, right Jayden?
Let me, there's a person in the front row.
Let's see if we can spot that guy,
I think he's wearing a gee.
He's got his bare chested and
he's giving me a lot of tude,
that is Ian Oliver, and I
believe he's wearing a gee.
He is dressed for combat,
and he looks like he wants to kick my ass
right across the street.
[Andy] It might be a bathrobe
and he might just be a drunk.
(laughing)
Back there, Andy, do you see
this person in the final row?
Yeah, the tux.
And I think this is kind
of yours, Andy, this--
I saw this guy, yeah, he does...
We are from the same sort of
gene pool of porridge faces.
Who is this gentlemen?
What's his name?
Chris Kabi.
Chris Kabi?
[Andy] Chris Kabi.
Well, I like Chris,
you clean up real nice,
and I liked that you had
the dignity to wear a tuxedo
to our show, no one's
done that in 30 years.
He has the Richter family
class, that's for sure.
(laughing)
Anyway, this is really exciting.
The audience is starting to fill out,
and I think in the following days,
we're gonna see this
audience completely filled
with fans of the show who
are excited to be here.
I think we're gonna have a packed house.
We won't be so lonely anymore.
We're not gonna be lonely at all.
The important thing is if you
want to join in all the fun,
go to teamcoco.com/cutouts,
send us your photo.
We'll put you in the crowd.
This is exciting.
This is us bobbing and weaving,
and playing with the situation
that we're in right now, man.
I think Jayden's face
says it all, right, buddy?
(laughs)
Yes, you too can be as happy as that guy.
So get in on the phone,
this is just a great way
to show that we're all in this together.